all right here's all the footage for the
salmon eco channel right click delete so
we've been looking to fix the camera
room up for a while we just got back
from Home Depot Derick and I and we've
just realized a pun building the shelves
that the raid is still in there the raid
is is basically the drive that
everything that corridors that were done
that's pretty important like how did
this happen how did this happen
the computer that the most people depend
on on a regular basis that never gets
shut off is sitting here shoved into a
corner like an abandoned child there's a
culmination of all of our hard work
forever huh but likely it's in my hands
so we're good look at the cable
management in there
don't look it look at that it's terrible
[Music]
hi this the right address wasn't sir
yeah today it's Monday morning and we're
at the DJI la headquarters
[Music]
from DJI today we're gonna meet with
some of our buddies here at DJI the
purpose of our visit today is I don't
know really what it is they told us they
had something to show us so we decided
to come in and see what that is
hopefully it's a drum stay in order to
give us the Mavic but they also wanted
to give us an on pre-production model
like they wanted to give us like the
final thing that isn't gonna like break
down in most videos you see online
youtubers when they get like a product
or something and before anyone else does
usually that product is like a prototype
model or a beta model it will work for
about a month or two but the moment
someone updates firmware if they're out
of business
we just want stuff that works cleaning
off the rage because it hasn't been done
in [ __ ] forever
[Music]
yep now that their rate is clean gonna
get it all set up nice and fresh give it
its own little desk in there and set up
the rest of the room the most powerful
computer in the whole building has the
worst [ __ ] cables ever something no
one ever took the [ __ ] time to do
then in this studio since 2014 haven't
had a [ __ ] cable that's actually been
managed ok man what are we missing out
on the new ones serious work and we're
like two people trying to put one camera
together been in the studio sunny blue
team's isolating who's gonna manage the
cables why the [ __ ] isn't this [ __ ]
[ __ ] man down
Gordo the musical
[Applause]
what's he doing placing the rock you
know and so yeah and we in terms of
getting up to your vision and then
trying to help you real business you do
seems pretty glamorous
oh man you get to work with big actors
and blow things up and make things look
all pretty and once in a while you get
to do that most of it is phone calls and
conference meetings sitting there
slogging through a script trying to
figure out what you can afford to shoot
how you're going to problem-solve all
this kind of stuff there's already a lot
of content you can watch on YouTube and
if we're just going to do more of the
same and there's no point in people
watching this on youtube read you're
going to tell a good story that really
hooks people you're going to dig into
emotions both good and bad it really
falls into kind of classic pillars of
like noir cinema not saying this is
black and white heart oil detectives I'm
calling it I guess neo noir playing
around a lot of more like the Moody or
aspects that you get from that kind of
cinema we were on the phone with some
folks over at YouTube we have some
YouTube influencers in this piece it's
gonna help it get some publicity help
people tune in because it's going to be
going on YouTube breath we're searing a
little bit away from the vlogger
perspective and trying to get a little
bit more into the sketch artist and
actor side of things for example Julian
Smith is another guy kind of sticks out
huh I'm not gonna drink it I make this
be you know I like this for you brings
characters to life regularly
so um you know in terms of today and
behind the scenes of the behind the
scenes we delete a lot of [ __ ] surge
unit right here is red and that storage
unit is the rate it's hang on hang on
hang on hang on
if this raid was to be deleted we would
lose everything
right here's all the footage the salmon
eco channel right-click delete and yes
started 99 gigabytes by deleting about
three months worth of behind-the-scenes
footage
I just gave everyone 1.5 terabyte you're
welcome Ren
[Applause]
[Music]